so the main villain of the batman is the
riddler a character who's always
honestly been one of my favorite batman
antagonists i mean in the comics he's
this guy that thinks he's so smart that
he leaves batman a bunch of puzzles to
solve in order to lead him right to the
crime scene it's like the nerdiest
attempt at a chad move ever which is why
i was so excited to see him here in this
movie reimagined as a terrifying masked
serial murderer a nightmarish zodiac
killer for the instagram age driven by
the single-minded goal of getting people
to watch his internet videos about the
deep lore of gotham city
oh no
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that encourages you to pull in
adam west and punch that subscribe
button so hard it says oof your glasses
remember never hit a man with glasses
well friends hot on the heels of the
huge success that was batman v superman
well it looks like it took some time but
the batman is finally set to take flight
here in 2018 2019 right in time for the
summer blockbusters for halloween for
the top of 2022 we finally have the
release of the ben affleck directed matt
reeves directed batman movie
starring ben affleck oh come on yes
friends we finally have ourselves a new
standalone batman movie the latest
feature film adaptation of the only
character in the dc comics universe that
warner brothers is apparently aware
exists i mean i would make the joke
myself but it looks like they've already
done it for me coming this summer
they're finally going to make a movie
about me
alfred the movie
the real punchline here is that by the
time that joke made it to theaters wb
had actually greenlit and alfred's show
my movie must be slated for next summer
coming next summer it's the car
oh they did the car before you bro and
now they're doing that one too what's up
dc kids fandom i'm really excited to
give you a little sneak peek into the
new show fat wheels even the upcoming
flash movie is apparently a batman movie
okay so maybe the world's a bit
saturated with batman content these days
which kind of makes it ironic that today
i don't want to talk about the movie
that we got instead i want to talk about
the movie that we're gonna get you see
since the release of the film the
internet's been buzzing with headlines
all about the big joker tease that
happens at the end of this movie just to
recap where we leave things off as the
batman concludes riddler aka edward
nashton turns out to basically be a
dorky batman fanboy who thought that he
was helping the crime fighting mission
with his clues and honestly batman needs
all the help he can get considering he
manages to thwart about like let's say
one third of the riddler's big evil
scheme sure just about every specific
person that ridler sets out to kill gets
killed and gotham city is flooded just
like he planned but
i i guess batman managed to stop like
most of an attack at a big political
event so yay along the way he learns
that in order to truly make gotham
better he's gonna need to check his
privilege brush up on his spanish and
recalibrate his branding a bit
considering that one of the gunman in
the finale repeats his i'm vengeance
catchphrase back to him it's a good
thing that he had already caught the
riddler at that point because it sounds
like he's gonna need a me day to process
that one speaking of catching the
riddler he gets one last scene moping in
a cell in arkham asylum and it's here
that we finally come to the conversation
that everyone's been talking about and
the one that i want to focus on for
today's episode since we obviously don't
have footage from the new movie let me
just set the scene a barren cell tint it
red redder redder no no really i mean
real red pretending like ketchup got
smeared across the film reel or
something yeah there it is perfect
riddler sad and confused paces in his
room suddenly a voice from the next cell
over says what is it they say
one day you're on top and the next
you're a clown well let me tell you
there are worse things than being
hey hey hey don't be sad you did so well
and you know gotham loves a comeback
story who are you well that's the
question isn't it riddle me this the
less of them you have the more one is
worth a friend and then they both laugh
but not like normal laughs they both
sound like two teenage boys swapping
fortnite memes on the playground and
scene now we don't get a good look at
who this person is the actor is barry
kyogen and he's credited only as unseen
arkham inmates but his face appears to
be somehow disfigured so between the
high-pitched pre-pubescent laughter the
clown references and the scars clearly
everyone is immediately thinking that
this guy is the joker and it certainly
makes sense he is the top batman villain
every version of this property is always
in a rush to get him in there and there
have been rumors that kyogen's
undisclosed role would specifically be a
version of the joker and yet i'm not so
sure uh matt it feels almost too easy
too predictable
not right now i'm trying to record
you're already a movie studio fighting
the perception that it keeps repeating
itself why would you make your big
build-up something that everyone was so
sure that they could see coming and at
the same time why would you take such a
huge risk any casting of the joker
immediately gets compared to heath
ledger's iconic portrayal in the dark
knight and that's just not a comparison
that many actors are able to win a bad
joker too early in your series can
really kill off your chances before you
even get a chance to spread your wings
isn't that right jared leto really bruce
honor we live in a society like i said
that's why i believe the batman is
actually pulling the wool over our eyes
they're misdirecting us they're setting
up a different batman arch nemesis one
that would work a lot better for the
world that this film's created a guy
named hush
seriously what i am trying to record yes
hi hello head editor dan here you really
might want to see this one of the lines
from the scene that's not in is that
unseen prisoner says to him he says it's
almost our anniversary isn't it and that
character who is the character that you
think he is wait so he's the character i
think he is did they already just
confirm my hush theory no no matt you're
missing the point here the reason that
joker's in the movie is batman is so
unnerved because the riddler is writing
to him and so he goes to see another
killer that he's clearly had an
experience with and this killer in this
story
is
not yet the character that we come to
know and so here we have a joker who's
not yet the joker oh yeah wait when did
this come out march 4th that is
literally the day that the movie
released they leave in a bunch of theory
fodder trademarks only to reveal the
answer the same day but but i i just
finished the script i i just got into
the recording booth i know buddy i know
it hurts life has been a cruel joke on
him and he's eventually going to become
declare himself as a clown declare
himself as the joker oh be quiet matt
reeves i get it you've done enough
damage
well there's a new salad fingers you
want to talk about that you should be
hush wait what he
should be hush yeah that's it they're
all wrong the director is wrong about
his own movie all of them the director
the studio everyone is wrong to insert
the joker into this world this character
should be hush it would work better it
would make more sense heck the easter
eggs are already there in the movie so
as long as you scrub all these director
interviews from the world you have
something that could really work you're
really going through with this uh going
through with what dan making the movie
better making these business decisions
over at wb and dc makes sense yeah yeah
i am now stand aside my friend i got a
theory to record all right good luck oh
boy created by jeff loeb and jim lee in
2002 hushes it's it's a little bit
complicated have you noticed that most
major batman villains are directly
commenting on the batman in some way
two-face is a guy with two personas like
someone who's rich during the day and a
bat vigilante at night the penguin is a
low-life criminal who kaz plays as a
rich aristocrat a direct commentary on
the billionaire who hunts him down
batman is a man pretending to be a bat
but what happens when you have a bat
pretending to be a man man bat look not
all of them need an elaborate
explanation but whereas all these other
villains are commentaries on batman hush
is the villain that's basically the evil
version of bruce wayne in the original
hush storyline a boy named thomas
elliott grows up as bruce's childhood
friend but whereas bruce wayne became
batman following the tragic murder of
his loving parents eliot's parents were
abusive and neglectful and his origin
begins by attempting to engineer their
deaths in an accident so he can inherit
the fortune but when the moment finally
comes elliott only manages to kill his
father his mother's life is actually
saved by thomas wayne thwarting his plan
for inheritance driving him further into
madness and leaving him with a permanent
grudge against the wayne family from
that starting point thomas elliot grows
up to become a brilliant surgeon with a
chip on his shoulder during the 11 issue
storyline he learns that bruce wayne is
batman and he becomes obsessed with
tearing him down to do this he
manipulates almost everyone including
joker poison ivy killer croc even
superman as a part of his elaborate
scheme and here's the kicker the reason
he knows the bruce batman connection
hush's secret partner figures it out the
one smart enough to put it all together
the riddler they team up they're friends
just like we see them becoming friends
in arkham at the end of the batman
that's it they shared a storyline and
worked together one time that's your big
evidence no no that's not it obviously
that would be way too big of a leap i
mean i don't want to be that guy but
have you seen these channels i'm gonna
choose to ignore that in this new movie
the riddler's grudge against the waynes
started when he was a kid living in an
orphanage set to be funded by a wayne
family charity initiative one that then
lost funding when the waynes got killed
right well the riddler has himself a
theory a conspiracy theory that their
death wasn't a random act of violence in
a rambling explainer video he tries to
prove that thomas wayne while running
for mayor of gotham asked for a hit on a
tabloid journalist that was set to do an
expose about his wife martha being
treated for mental illness at arkham
when the deal goes south the waynes get
killed but what's important here are the
images that flash across the screen the
journalist who supposedly gets killed is
named edward elliott and then we see the
word hush scrawled across the tv screen
elliot hush they're trying to tell us
something it's an easter egg sure it's
pretty explicit but what is it that our
scarred friend says in his dialogue at
the end of the new movie everyone loves
a comeback story that line it doesn't
really make a lot of sense if we assume
that this is the joker oh no he was
caught off screen in batman's first year
in a movie that never got made and now
he's back in the sequel sure i guess but
what if this guy was thought to be dead
and is looking to surprise everyone with
his return now the line really fits
edward elliot or better yet what if it's
edward elliot's son coming back thomas
another child who's made an orphan
thanks to the corruption of gotham but
unlike bruce who grows up and
internalizes that to become a force for
good this kid grows up to take a
different path one of spreading fear and
murder that comeback line also makes a
lot of sense with hush's history he
himself is a comeback story from bruce
and his childhood spent together and his
big plot to take down batman in the
comics revolves around making it seem
like jason todd has come back from the
dead everyone loves a comeback story i
mean sure but the director said but
beyond the riddler connection and the
easter eggs hidden film hush makes the
most sense to use for this version of
batman this batman is a detective he
walks around slowly he monologues about
his thoughts slowly he solves mysteries
slowly and hush is very much a crime
noir villain someone manipulating things
from the shadows pulling the strings he
tends to work best in any story where
elaborate conspiracies are afoot or
people are digging into the not so pure
pasts of thomas and martha wayne just
like the riddler is doing here in this
first movie hush comes from comic story
lines like batman r.i.p and heart of
hush where villains dig into the old
dark rumors of the wayne family's
connections to things like drug scandals
and the accusations that alfred is
bruce's biological father thematically
too thomas elliott just makes more sense
the batman's version of bruce wayne is
not a perfect guy who's figured out his
entire mission yet he essentially gets
dressed down to his face by catwoman
about how it's actually guys like bruce
wayne who are the problem in places like
gotham and in that context a villain
like thomas elliot is hush someone from
bruce wayne's world who's living the
same kind of double life but with the
mirror opposite values and mission would
be the perfect way to continue driving
that point home you're done speaking of
selena kyle hush kidnaps her then
surgically removes her heart and holds
it hostage in a story arc so you know in
this new film universe he would have her
hanging out and available for that that
one's kind of weird not gonna lie but
also look at the casting and design of
this guy well barry keoghan's disfigured
joker face is meant to be a birth defect
that forces his version of the character
into a permanent smile he's got this
congenital disease he can never stop
smiling what if this is something that
he's been touched by from birth and he's
had this very dark reaction to it and he
knows how to get into your head we know
from the comics that hush's face is
constantly wrapped in bandages like some
sort of invisible man cosplay he does
this to hide the fact that he's done
surgery on his own face so if they
wanted barry to suddenly not be the
joker you could just say oh yeah these
are bad plastic surgery scars also it's
worth mentioning that thomas elliot does
surgery on his own face to become bruce
wayne he literally changes his face to
become a doppelganger for bruce in a
film universe where bruce is a recluse
and hiding inside the batman cowl for
like 95 of the runtime it leaves the
door open for hush to take on bruce's
identity out in the daylight to cause
some havoc at which point the real bruce
needs to deal with his and his family's
demons to realize that hey being a
privileged rich kid comes with
responsibilities that you can't just
dress up and punch through to avoid in
fact that movie would force bruce to
realize that bruce wayne based on all
his money and privilege probably has
more changing power than batman ever did
with his fists okay that's kind of cool
i recognize that i pay you to say that
but i appreciate you doing it anyway we
also need to consider age here joker in
most media is meant to be older than
batman by about 10 years whereas hush is
meant to be batman's contemporary they
grew up together as childhood frenemies
at 29 barry kyogen is a good bit younger
than 35 year old robert pattinson's
batman that age gap could certainly work
with a hush dynamic but it would
definitely be a bit unusual to see it
played out in the form of joker and
lastly during the end credits of this
new movie you're hinted to go to a
website
www.rotalata the winged rat which is
meant to be the riddler's sight it's
actually been kicking around since the
movie's early trailers but now it's
constantly being updated with new
riddler files so you can dig around
inside his conspiracy lots of them are
just really cool assets from the movie
you get close-up shots of riddler's
sanctuary some of the surveillance
photos that he took of the corrupt elite
martha wayne being treated at arkham and
of course plenty of ciphers to solve for
when you finished your daily dose of
wordle i got it in for today five thanks
for rubbing it in anyway this file is
super cool and i highly recommend that
everyone watching check it out but there
are two files in the zip drive that i
wanted to call out specifically first in
picture zero one we get a man missing a
face wrapped in bandages that could be
his victims just wrapped up in duct tape
agreed but i just wanted to point it out
what's much more interesting though is
riddler's journal it's a nine-page pdf
where we see his descent and madness it
starts with him suspecting that
something's wrong in the city he's
frustrated by the elite sitting on their
thrones and he's determined to find the
corruption that exists under the surface
by the end though he's filling the pages
with line after line of renewal i know
what i must become and no escape just
page after page after page of rambling
and scribbling looking at it it was
suspicious to me that they included so
much of this so i decided to look closer
and when you do you can start to make
out some shapes things that kind of look
like the shape of eyeballs so i darken
the image and you clearly get faces two
strong points for batman's ears his
glaring eyes and someone lurking behind
him is it just the riddler sure maybe
probably but i like to think that this
whole rabbit hole of an arg is hinting
at what's coming next and that face to
me is very similar to what we see of
hush legitimately that's pretty cool
regardless of whether it's hush or not
here's the tl dr do i think that barry
kyogen is likely meant to be the joker
yes he is again that was outright
confirmed but i hope that he isn't
batman's rogues gallery is stacked with
amazing characters that were all built
to reveal interesting facets of the
character i get why everyone is in such
a rush to pull out a joker but guess
what story matters more the dark knight
worked not just because the joker was in
it but because the team making the movie
understood why the joker was in it and
spoiler alert the answer wasn't just to
sell tickets don't get me wrong i love
the character i thought the new joker
movie was great but we see him all the
time batman has 26 animated films and
joker makes an appearance in at least 16
of them that's 61
in live action movies we've seen the
joker five times in the last 30 years on
tv gotham gave us like three people who
weren't technically the joker but were
obviously kind of the joker i'm just
excited to see something different with
these characters and this new batman
movie started to give me it and i want
that to continue when i look at the
world of this new movie hush feels like
a perfect fit there's comic lore
connecting him to the riddler the easter
eggs that have already been laid out for
mr jay could just as easily transplant
over onto thomas elliott oh scarred
bruce wayne doppelganger and honestly i
think the story potential there is just
as strong if not stronger in the end my
point is that i love all these
characters and sometimes by seeing less
of one it allows us to see more of all
of them but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cut
um so i just leave right matt didn't
really say goodbye so i just kind of
stayed for the end card um oh end card
well i guess you can click this video
here that'll that'll take you to the
theory or there's this one right here
you can click that one as well that'd be
neat uh subscribe you know helps us keep
our jobs i guess i will see my way out